every policy probably has a machete I'm
I'm not sure that everything is actually
heads in the Chevy at their house so to
start off can you please introduce
yourself my name is Tara bloom and I'm
fully artist normally in a Foley session
they roll the beeps and then picture
will follow and then we will perform in
the same picture
[Music]
mostly because I figured that I could
replicate what in that video like not
very precise and like the sound quality
was not very good first off i muted the
sound and then watched it a couple times
on silently because what I was trying to
do is is match picture that's normally
how we get a project there is no sound
I knew I wanted to use the machete just
to give a blade sound for the chainsaw
when I was first performing it I was
imagining closing this on itself so
we're getting like an insert sound of it
but it wasn't it wasn't really giving me
an insert sound so as I was performing
it I ended up just going with picture
you can hear how the cavity of it is
giving you like an insert and then just
the blade ricocheting at the same time
I'm not actually looking at picture
while performing that was the biggest
challenge to me the gate outside my door
I took from my neighbor cuz they left it
out for trash I was gonna change it into
like a succulent all the other thing is
a plantar fasciitis like a foot fashio
roller like the first would squeak that
happens yeah I've always noticed the
squeak on that thing
the only chain I have is a bike lock
chain like I know how certain things
sound in my kitchen and I don't know
yeah I think it's just a just because of
the nature of the job
I don't have real lightbulbs at my house
they're all energy-saving and they don't
sound like my balls so I ended up
thinking like an old lantern that I have
and a chain on it but I just grabbed a
bunch of different metal objects that I
have just to create different metal
rattles in the visual it's like running
on screws and stuff so you can like see
a bunch of different metal rattling
there's like brackets that get thrown
down one after the other the closest
thing I have to that are Spurs the
screwdriver we typically wouldn't cover
but I just figured that I should do
something because this is a fully
exercise so I just used a screw on the
machete every Foley stage probably has a
machete or two I'm I'm not sure that
every Foley artist actually had to the
shedding of their house I also have a
full-size axe
so I just wanted to provide like a metal
squeak and then like a closure sound and
I'm holding it with my foot because I I
also didn't want to edit it and I wanted
it to happen just like the visual
happens so you have to like really be
precise with your action so that became
kind of difficult just because it had to
be right in sync and I wasn't really
watching the picture so I actually built
that prop the leather straps for
Westworld for the samurai character she
can't hear very much of but it's an that
take was pretty hard to do because I was
fighting the level of the metal on the
table to the leather the metal was
overtaking the leather sound I added a
piece of cloth underneath the piece of
metal I was grabbing the leather harness
that tightened I would have done like a
rope grab kind of sound and then I would
have also done a leather Creek on top of
that but having to do it simultaneously
with death with a challenge
the crock-pot was right in front of me
so I'm mine and immediately was like
what can i stuff in there that's gonna
give me like a sound that something is
going into something also I was
recording in this space I was worried
about it cuz it's obviously super live
the ceilings are really high in the
floors wood and actually worked out
honestly when I chose this room as
because of this surface sound sorry cam
saw that was just giving me like a large
plastic kind of chainsaw body kind of
thing the other thing is actually
airsoft handgun I obviously needed the
sound of the chainsaw starting like the
cable pole I would have used something
way different on the only stage you're
probably but I used to chain up against
like a big body of plastic or something
just pretty well I just used the body of
a bucket and it's actually almost
countable because of the visual because
it doesn't work he pulls it you're like
dies out and she like expels like air
[Music]
that's actually sounds fully of a
chainsaw would be the handling of a
chainsaw the grab of the cable and then
running of a chainsaw is an effect sound
not full so for like a gun a gunshot
would be an effect and then the movement
of the gun this is actually a garden you
know trellis stick those whooshing
sounds are always made by a doily
Adelie is just a thin stick when
thrusted through the air creates a high
pitch whoosh sound the different shapes
of different sticks make different lower
lower wishes or higher pitch wishes kind
of interesting
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
why didn't you just do the sound effects
on your own and then and edit try and
like match it up wait here for me to
just perform I'm right in sync